-Performing "Lie To Me,"
from their new album,
"Ghetto Gods,"
give it up for Earthgang!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Oh, oh oh, oh oh ♪
-Birkin bags
are a hot commodity.
♪ She got a Birkin,
flossin', money well spent ♪
-♪ She still in them 'partments
payin' rent ♪
-♪ Saturday, Sunday,
he got cash to play ♪
-♪ Monday come,
his pockets full of lint ♪
-♪ Oh, can you be honest ♪
♪ Can you be true ♪
-♪ Keep it one hundred,
tell me the truth ♪
-♪ Can you be honest?
Can you be true? ♪
♪ Anybody straight up?
Lie on cue ♪
♪ Anybody keepin' it real
with you? ♪
♪ Keep it one hundred,
tell me the truth ♪
♪ Everybody buy your things,
rely on things ♪
♪ To prove your status,
prove you have it, whoo ♪
♪ Now they caught up in a role
they can't fulfill ♪
♪ They can't be real,
it's too dramatic ♪
♪ Gotta keep
the audience happy ♪
the haters guessin' ♪
♪ Livin' a lie for folks
you'll never meet in real life ♪
♪ So tragic ♪
♪ Baby got a day job,
it goes somethin' like this, ♪
♪ Upload-upload, check
engagement, receive payments ♪
♪ Grantin' fantasies,
sellin' hella dreams ♪
♪ Then she takes her mask off ♪
♪ Fenty runnin' down
her breast ♪
♪ Her true self,
hope she don't forget ♪
♪ Say she do it for the check ♪
♪ My homeboy lie
for his respect ♪
♪ Can't wait to flex
the new baguettes ♪
♪ 'Cause the world
we live in keep revealin' ♪
♪ If you ain't ballin',
then you ain't... ♪
♪ So she gon' buy Chanel
to impress ♪
♪ He gon' shop
'til ain't nothin' left ♪
♪ They fell in love with the
fake 'til the real came out ♪
♪ Now they at
each other's neck ♪
-♪ She got a Birkin,
flossin', money well spent ♪
-♪ She got a Birkin ♪
-♪ She still in them 'partments
payin' rent ♪
-♪ She in them 'partments
still ♪
-♪ Saturday, Sunday,
he got cash to play ♪
♪ Monday come,
his pockets full of lint ♪
-♪ Can you be honest?
Can you be true ♪
♪ Anybody straight up?
Lie on cue ♪
♪ Anybody keepin' it real
with you? ♪
♪ Keep it one hundred,
tell me the truth ♪
♪ Can you be honest?
Can you be true? ♪
♪ Anybody straight up,
lie on cue ♪
♪ Anybody keepin' it real
with you? ♪
♪ Keep it one hundred,
tell me the truth ♪
-♪ Closed mouth don't eat ♪
-♪ Broke finger don't tweet ♪
-♪ Broke people gon' hate ♪
-♪ To distract from defeat ♪
♪ Look away,
how you livin' these days? ♪
♪ Love languages and tags
and receipts ♪
♪ Whoop-whoop, get the penalty
paid out quick ♪
♪ Right back to the street ♪
♪ Flewed out on the front
of the plane like, "Hey" ♪
♪ I ain't really that cheap,
she don't really know me ♪
♪ She just wanna take pics,
she just wanna take pics ♪
♪ Wanna see the beach,
brother like me ♪
♪ Had to get it out the mud,
these really my cleats ♪
♪ This really my blood,
I'm really Denzel ♪
♪ One tear on my cheek,
rollin' up... ♪
♪ She talkin' 'bout minks,
I'm talkin' 'bout think ♪
♪ When you figure out
what you need ♪
♪ Let it get back to me ♪
♪ ...from the factory ♪
♪ Run through...like batteries ♪
♪ Every...with a strategy ♪
♪ And she got it perfect,
she got a purpose ♪
♪ She got a system,
know how to work it ♪
♪ That's how she gotta,
she gotta, yeah ♪
-♪ She got a Birkin,
flossin', money well spent ♪
-♪ Uh-huh ♪
♪ But she still in them
'partments payin' rent ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Saturday, Sunday,
he got cash to play ♪
♪ Monday come,
his pockets full of lint ♪
♪ Can you be honest?
Can you be true? ♪
♪ Anybody straight up?
Lie on cue ♪
♪ Anybody keepin' it real
with you? ♪
♪ Keep it one hundred,
tell me the truth ♪
♪ Can you be honest? ♪
♪ Can you be true? ♪
-♪ Ladies ♪
-♪ Here we go, ladies ♪
Come on!
-♪ Perception ♪
♪ Of self-perfection
give me erections ♪
-♪ Hey, hey ♪
-♪ Lie to me, lie to me,
lie to me ♪
-Everybody!
-♪ Oh ♪
♪ Perceptions of perfection
give me erections ♪
♪ Lie to me, lie to me,
baby, lie to me ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Lie to me, lie to me,
lie to me ♪
-♪ Whoa-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh, oh oh ♪
-♪ Lie to me, lie to me,
lie to me ♪
-♪ Lie to me ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]